hello and welcome to Magnus trainer I am
once again here fooling around in the
app and today I wanted to play a game
called flying control which is one of my
personal favorites so it's a game about
the coordination of well the board which
is of course highly useful to master
because of course when you play a
standard game you have to write down all
the moves so it's a brilliant way to
teach yourself that so that's what we
are going to do today I am going to
attempt this and let's see how I fare
I'm gonna try a level on easy medium and
hard so you can see how the difficulty
just Rams up eventually so enough with
the intro let's jump into level 1 which
is the easiest level land 10 planes in
order to win all right
I am ready ready my entire life a 1 e 2
a 7 alright so this is going pretty well
not hard whatsoever so very nice indeed
of course this is the first level so
it's supposed to be fairly easy and
indeed that is I have already completed
it but of course I'm gonna try to I'm
gonna try to get all three stars cuz you
know it's pretty nice so we have a 7 e 1
f1 pretty nice music - relaxing music
maybe a little bit annoying to listen to
if you if you fail but yeah I'm loving
this I'm loving this a 5 a 2 and we are
in business before pretty simple indeed
we have all the time in the world in
order to do this correctly so yeah
fairly a walk in the park of course but
of course it's the first level so you
won you bet level one so let's continue
so let's try to find a level that's kind
of in the middle so I have already
completed level 10 and 12 so let's try
level 11 so we have to land 27 planes
now in order to win which is 17 more and
then the first level so of course things
are a little bit harder and the speed a
significantly faster a 1g1
still not a problem for a guy like
myself to handle definitely not a three
a six I do get a little bit dizzy by
looking at it though so getting messages
as well which kind of funny but pretty
funky I'm enjoying it slightly faster
though and I'm I fast enough for that
well windows so A to E 4 E to H 8 a 4
that's pretty nice so B 3 D 5 so yeah a
lot of messages there and
once again medium beaten just like that
let's see if we can try to handle the
hardest difficulty the hardest
difficulty of flight control can we do
it
level 18 land 35 planes in order to win
holy that's gonna be that's gonna be
hard
let's see though if we can do it so get
set and go
Oh more drawings first which 1 H 2 d 6
I'm too slow G 3 h 6h o d 6 how am I
supposed to do this f 7 it goes is just
too fast too fast for me Oh yikes this
is way too hard oh that was we got one
at least are we gonna get another one
are we gonna get another one before we
run out of time no no we're not we're
not gonna get it
c5 e 7 no this is before we got that one
h 1 c 2 maybe age 6 geez
I give up H oh you can see it right
there ok so you have to look at that
number
oh okay that's the revelation that's a
revelation I can do it
skip no thank you I'm gonna try I did so
poorly that the game tries to tell me
that I should probably do this later and
no I'm ready okay better seating
position let's go so we have to like
take a look at the number and then click
a true B 1 a 7 g 4 a 2 B 2 B 5 y 8
h7 f8 come on Sebastian come on you can
do it you can do it are we gonna be able
to pull this off are we we might we
might be able to do it
hey for f3g 8h to g4 I'm getting too
dizzy I'm d4 d5 oops
d7 let's see can I do it how many planes
they said how many do we need to get we
need to get 35 it's just too much
too many at the same time can we do it
[Music]
we did that was awesome that was awesome
that was awesome
so that was intense I have to say that
was intense I'm breathless I really am
all right that was pretty a pretty good
pretty fun
great stuff certainly very hard in the
last one that was a level 18 I
unfortunately I couldn't get three stars
though but we'll just have to live with
that and yeah that's all I had for you
guys today
once again flight control is a wonderful
way to test your coordination skills
good way of doing so so as always thank
you so much for for watching and I will
see you soon on play Magnus
you
[Music]